national hispanic heritage month kicks
off today and during a month-long
celebration we will highlight the
diverse cultures from all over latin
america so tonight we're going to be
profiling actor danny trejo he is one of
the most recognizable character actors
in movies and in television but his road
to success was not an easy one sam rubin
chatted with the actor about his life of
crime and his road to redemption
he's played countless tough guys on the
big and small screen i played inmate
number one i played bad guy i played a
chicano dude i played a guy with tattoos
i i never had a name now he's one of the
biggest names in hollywood in town danny
trejo is known as the nicest bad guy
someone who's always giving back to his
community everything good sam that has
happened to me has happened as a direct
result of helping someone else
everything that's the way i live but he
didn't always live that way trejo spent
his youth in and out of prison you know
you have to understand it in 1968
i didn't know if i was going to live
another day
but he turned his life around getting
sober and becoming a drug counselor and
it was helping others trying to stay
clean that led him to the set of the
1985 film runaway train i walked on this
movie said uh guy says hey you want to
be in this movie and that's what i got
to do
be an extra can you act like an economy
i almost started laughing right in every
institute in the state of california
i'll give it a shot that one shot led to
a career spanning over three decades
with over 300 tv and film credits
including machete and the popular spy
kids films what does it feel like to you
to be that guy
i think it's such an honor i still got
kids five and six years old coming over
i love you i mean it's like such a such
a blessing in addition to the big
hollywood career trejo is also a
successful restaurateur people call us
hey we're having this fundraiser blah
blah blah okay we'll send tacos
and bowls that's what we do that's why
we're in business
this is all terrific when you see your
happy customers when you see families
coming in
what is it what do you think i feel like
they're coming into my living room we're
having food in my kitchen you know
we made it here enjoy and i i love the
feeling of
home
i've heard the tacos are amazing too
that was sam rubin reporting trejos
tacos recipes and stories from la and
his memoir trejo my life of crime
redemption and hollywood available now
what a fantastic actor well joining us
this weekend as we share stories of
people in places who have helped
southern nevada grow into the diverse
community we know and love today our
hispanic heritage special air saturday
night at 6 30. good to see